hello very good morning to you we start
with some unexpected news on the economy
UK GDP grew marginally in November
reducing the risk of the country
entering a recession analysts had
expected that the economy would instead
shrink and so the slight rise was
supported by the technology sector and a
strong showing by pubs and bars during
the World Cup so monthly GDP the
standard measure of the size of the
economy was up by 0.1 percent in
November now this comes on the back of
0.5 percent growth in October when
economic activity returned to normal
after the Queen's funeral in September
the additional bank holiday for the
Queen's funeral saw most businesses
close and it contributed to a 0.6
contraction of the economy
and looking at the broader picture GDP
fell by 0.3 percent in the three months
to November
well this is what the shadow Northern
Ireland secretary Peter Kyle told me
earlier in reaction
a sign of basically effectively no
growth actually isn't a sign of success
for our economy what we need to be doing
is having a much more fundamental
rethink about how our economy is being
run link it to the industrial action at
the moment link it to the failure in
public services when you have seven
million people waiting for treatment on
the AHS that is seven million people who
are unable to fully engage in the
economy in work uh who are we taking
time off six so it's not just about the
fundamentals of direct economic policy
that we need to look at it is the
running of our public services in our
country which is which is preventing us
from fully exploring our potential as a
country and individuals out there in the
economy
well let's bring in our correspondent
Mario Aurora for more on this so This
figure marginally into positive
territory and Mario but that still more
than was expected wasn't it it
definitely is Anno and I think that is
the kind of positive news of today is
the expectation as you say it was about
0.2 contraction and now we've got 0.1
growth so it is it is good news
financially for the country I think you
know it's important to remember GDP is
the kind of way to gauge the financial
the economic health of a nation and
therefore the fact that we've had growth
in November these are only monthly
figures they're not quarterly figures so
we still don't know about Q4 yet for
2022 but the fact that we had growth and
we also had growth in in October as well
that is technically two months of growth
albeit very small therefore it is kind
of like a bit of Light Relief I would
say for the government now uh Jeremy
Hunt the chancellor has spoken out in
reaction to these figures he says we
have a clear plan to half inflation this
year an Insidious hidden tax which has
led to hikes in interest rates and
mortgage costs holding back growth here
and around the world to support families
through this type of patch we will
provide an average of three and a half
thousand pound support for every
household over this year and next but
the most important help we can give is
to stick to the plan to half inflation
this year so we can get the economy
growing again so you know there was a
very cautious response there I think the
government are very much not wanting to
get carried away with the good news it
is still a small amount of growth but
nonetheless I think it is going to be to
an extent a way the government can try
and say they're proving that they can be
trusted with the country's finances and
they are the right people for the job
especially after the Fiasco of the mini
budget we saw earlier in 2022. okay
Murray thanks very much indeed